- Rien ne semble pouvoir
ralentir sa course.
vacille, puis touche le sol.
(explosion)
Les secouristes et les curieux
enflammée. L'écrasement dans un
ravin n'a laissé aucune chance
aux 68 passagers et quatre
membres de l'équipage. On a bien
tenté d'éteindre le brasier,
"L'opération de sauvetage s'est
avérée très difficile", souligne
ce policier. Plus d'une centaine
de militaires y ont participé.
Six enfants se trouvaient
se désole le premier ministre
du Népal, qui a convoqué
son cabinet pour
une réunion d'urgence.
L'ATR 72, un avion de ligne
partait de la capitale,
Katmandou, puis s'est écra
près de l'atterrissage
au nouvel aéroport de Pokhara,
inauguré le
Cette destination est courue
tant par p p pèlerins
que les randonneurs.
Parmi les passagers,15151515 re.
Depuis 2010, le petit pays'H'He
une dizaine d'écrasements
d'avions et d'hélicoptères.
Plus d'une centaine de peronono.
JEAN LAPOINTE,
expert en aviation civile
- Les pistes en montagne
montagnes, malheureusement, les
conditions météorologiques sont
exigeantes et, souvent, vont
changer rapidement, ce qui est
En plus d'uilililililililililié
des compagnies aériennes
népalaises est remise en doute.
L'Union européenne leur interdit
d'aiaéaéaéaéaéaéaéaéaéaéaéaéaéa.
L'enquête, déjà en cours,
devrait soulever cette fois-ci
un mélange de problèmes
de pilotage, selon cet expert
en aviation ci
- Les boîtes noires
le confirmer
C'est clairement un décrochage,
donc c'eiririririre que l'avione
va plus assez vite pour voler,
et à
- Cette dernière tragédie
en flululululus meurtrière
en 30 ans au Népal.
Ici Jean-Philippe Hughes,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.